or they just or every time he says the f
word they just
have a picture of uh a video of ship uh
i'm sorry uh eddie murphy now and he's
one
no yeah but he's just all old as [ __ ]
hannah
hannah and that's not her name not her
name
got it yeah should you please replace uh
crystalline in that uh action mode no
she did not it was it was two wait
that's not rachel maddow
that's not rachel hey that's
it
i'll tell you what some fan did dude
when that when that special came out
some fan because i made a joke about i
mean i tweeted about
how her next special was gonna be at the
apollo because like you know
and somebody cut her special in with
apollo hilarious no the
audience and it was like she was doing
her jokes like her the dry whatever
and the crowd was going crazy
crate dude that would be i mean that
that would be a funny show idea to put
comics in rooms
that like not their audience or at least
just take any comic and put them
in front of a black audience no because
you got 10 to 20 seconds to bring it get
it going yes
if you lean against the wall for one
second it's a wrap you'll just hear a
black woman in the crowd suck her teeth
so hard
and you'll hear like uh
so he was like yo you give me up he he
went up he was a white comic white guy
spots in the hood is it uh is it is it
is it a good white comic
yeah he fought for like he's slow like
it's dry yeah but you got it but you
can't you can't you can't bring that
yeah
you gotta go out kick
you only have 10 seconds to catch the
attention span and black crowds want
they want to feel that you are funny
yeah yeah they don't want to know your
material they want to be like you're
funny just like a vehicle
yeah let me see this uh cut of hannah
oh here it is
i've never seen it so funny dude
[Applause]
he did this on my tweet
[Laughter]
it's so funny
comfortable in a small town i get a bit
tense uh mainly because i'm in this
situation
you know blue is a cold color it's on
the cold end of the spectrum
but the hottest part of the flame blue
where does that come from
you're trying to hear booze
[Applause]
[Applause]
where's the saying man
keep going
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why does she get so much heat for it's
just a special he was just
he was because like the woke laughs it
made that special like
this is how special should be and it was
more of like a ted talk it was like an
article
she was quoted as saying like uh comedy
shouldn't be funny anymore
it should be like instructive so the
whole thing was like a ted talk and she
was kind of just
the whole thing was kind of just like
guys are bad yeah i was like opinions
yeah oh like how toxic male 1
she's a feminist lesbian from from
australia so the whole thing was kind of
like i don't get how like that why like
why that
would need to be comedy like why can't
comedy just be
she's a comedian she did the special and
then all these articles immediately just
came out
praising them praising it praising it as
like the [ __ ] oh this is the new comedy
then society is like society was like
huh yeah if you push it like that i'm
gonna go i'm gonna watch it yeah
and so everybody watching it was like
everyone watched it and uh people hated
it
including gay people like my brother's
gay and he was like what like yeah he
just didn't get
yeah i had i knew someone who went to
see her who's gay
and she just like it was a live
performance in new york and she just
started bombing and screaming at the
crowd
and got angry and like walked off so
it's like yeah it was one of those
things for me it was just further
evidence that like hey man when you get
in that system that system has an agenda
and they try to tell you what's good or
bad and it's based on like
yeah the public decides wait what do you
mean like the the
the entertainment system the machine the
machine
this is funny now easy for them to write
the article and put the [ __ ] out but it
doesn't because it's different
yeah you got the battery behind yeah
there's like exactly and then they're
going like they're
they're go not only are they going like
here this is what we're going to show
you they're going like
this is what good is so you read the
article and i guess people are going
like
i guess it's good but then you watch it
you go like that doesn't it that didn't
move
me yeah i think i kind of they kind of
screwed it over
no no i just no she got they got rave
reviews i bet
for her audience they loved it oh so
she's probably still killing it
oh yeah i think it's for her i think
it's falling a lot i don't i
don't i don't know much about it yeah i
think i don't know but i don't know her
yeah i don't know
but for her lane maybe they probably
[ __ ] with it
yeah her yeah her specific audience as
far as comedy you show up and it's just
like a bunch of lesbian couples
just sitting there with haircuts like
mine yeah
it's not going to be strong she's got
she's got her audience she can't perform
in front of
a diver it's it's the irony is she could
never perform in front of a diverse
crowd
that's what's always the irony to me is
like you go to some of those like all
rooms or you used to a couple years ago
yeah and it was like all this
righteousness and you go like this is
the whitest comedy show i've ever been
to
like everyone in the audience is white
yeah you know so you you
you would do a lot of black rooms when
you started i started doing black rooms
yeah
which is like scary yeah they're scary
but it's the best
it's the best because i think the part
of it you get so scared at the beginning
it gets easier than that and also you
realize that hey man it's a performance
yes like you can't just lean up in new
york a lot like
this is where we we lack too cool for
school yeah we kind of
leaned back and we're like yeah did you
hear the joke though
yeah structure the material like dude
you're telling you're telling jokes
you're not [ __ ] painting a picasso
nobody gives you so it's like bringing
me back and
like you know just like the the craft or
it's like la
it performs it it's like more a little
more theatrical
and in black rooms you have to perform
yeah you can't and black people aren't
going to write a blog if you say
something
no they're not going to write a blog
they're going to let you know right
there yeah that's right you know
there and then christmas you'll hear it
next
time is there a loud cough orange
there was just a [ __ ] chicken wing
bone got thrown out no
that big jake yeah kevin hart was like
great have you ever
hunt if you ever have a month i love big
j dude the philly store
kevin hart was hosting and like yeah he
started bombing and then
he used to do this thing i don't want to
ruin it but i'll just tell you quickly
he used to do this thing where he
stripped naked at the end because he's a
big bad person yeah yeah it's before you
know he's
an amazing comment yeah yeah yeah it's
like at the beginning you know we're all
trying to get laughs so he would strip
down naked as a big fat dude and the
crowd would go crazy
but he was doing this show of the black
black room in philly kevin hart was
hosting
and he was getting ready for his closer
which usually brings you how
crazy he's like all right he starts
stripping and at one point he just
he said he hears some black women go
jesus
and then he gets naked he just sees a
chicken bone just
[Laughter]
and then when he's done he does the big
finale it's silent then he's got to like
gather up
all his clothes silence oh yes he's
still got him just rolls
rolling down oh [ __ ] he's committed to
that [ __ ]
just built like a baby hippo [ __ ]
that's my time guys yeah that's fine did
you ever hear you was telling us
he had a serious show with uh dan soder
i think they still do it they still do
it they're great together
they're so [ __ ] funny two of the
funniest guys the funniest ever dance
from denver so i always [ __ ] with dan
but he was he was saying that you know
obviously he came up with kevin hart and
philly and he was like yeah and then
you know kevin blew up and i did i
didn't know how to you know i was like
hey i see him philly may want to come
through and he's like yeah sure man
and he's like so i come up there and
whenever we're on the road i used to
always bring the xbox and i was the xbox
guy
he's like so i come with my xbox i get
in there and ken's like man what the
[ __ ] you doing he's like what
he has like all the old controllers and
kevin what the [ __ ] are you doing
they're like in this penthouse he's like
i brought the xbox dude he goes so we
have like six of those
i buy one every city we go to and he was
like oh no doubt
he's like this is stupid that's the
moment where you're just really clearly
going oh yeah we're
too social yeah
like you invite your richer friend over
to your house and he comes over for five
seconds he's like
all right man let's just let's go to my
place
we always
[Laughter]
you know comedy's hard like that when
you come up with guys because guys
pop at different times and they're
friends yeah and a lot of times
actually yeah jealousy starts happening
and guys start
you you hear it all the times you look
back i've heard from all the comics you
know they got into fights because
one guy started popping the other guy
and it's just that's tough relationships
yeah relate you like but then also you
hear it all the time he's not even funny
yeah yeah yeah well some people think
he's really funny yeah
like he's selling out on the road you
really he's not funny he's got to be
doing something he's doing something
yeah
yeah he's not that's there's it's not
funny he's last special it's like oh god
dude
yeah it's like somebody thinks he's
funny
that room full of people who are
laughing think he's funny yeah yeah you
may not
yeah doing something right how about
that when i get off stage at the lab
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son